Моє запитання, пане Джоане: які висновки, на Вашу думку, повинна зробити з усього цього Україна,
з огляду на те, що вона також отримує дуже гарні слова і обіцянки від НАТО.
Приміром, про те, що "підтримка суверенітету і територіальної цілісності України є непохитною", тоді як фактично такі фрази, по суті, безглузді, чи не так?
Тому що НАТО нічого не може зробити, щоб запобігти порушенню суверенітету і територіальної цілісності України з боку Росії, що триває з 2014 року.
Отже, красиві слова. Лише красиві слова…
Це не лише слова…
Це те, чим ви хочете прославитися? Гарними словами?
Абсолютно навпаки. Не слід порівнювати непорівнювані речі. Афганістан - це не Україна.
І це зовсім інша гра і різні історії, які стоять за цими двома ситуаціями.
Дозвольте мені уточнити…
Згадайте, згадайте, якщо казати  про незаконну анексію Криму...
Чи пам'ятаємо ми, що країни Балтії були анексовані Радянським Союзом і були ті ж слова, як ви щойно згадали:
США і Західна Європа за часів, коли НАТО ще була зовсім невеликою організацією, заявили, що ніколи не визнають анексію країн Балтії
Радянським Союзом. Це може зайняти час. Це зайняло десятиліття, нам потрібно було дочекатися закінчення "холодної війни".
І сьогодні країни Балтії є гордими членами нашого Альянсу.
Я знаю, що в інтерв'ю з моїми колегами, з Йенсом Столтенбергом і моєю попередницею Роуз Гетемюллер, ви задавали питання,
чи дійсно ми можемо захистити ці країни - наших союзників? Так, можемо!
Чи є у нас зобов'язання щодо України в межах 5-ої статті? Поки немає.
Але коли і якщо у нас буде таке рішення, ми будемо захищати всіх наших членів.
Сьогодні у нас їх 30, і ми урочисто обіцяли захищати один одного.
Я знаю, що іноді слова недостатньо сильні, Тіме, але вони все-таки дещо значать.
Вони означають прихильність лідерів країн-членів НАТО нашим політичним принципам.
І в той момент, коли ми вирішили на нашому саміті НАТО в червні, що ми будемо продовжувати допомагати Афганістану,
що ми будемо продовжувати підтримувати суверенітет і територіальну цілісність України і Грузії, то це означає,
що ми будемо допомагати нашим партнерам по цілому світу. Така репутація НАТО. Це те, що ми робимо, не для того, щоб вести тривалі, затяжні війни.
Пане Джоане, вам же не потрібно, щоб я вам сказав...
Адже, напевно, не потрібно говорити вам, що український уряд чекає оголошення дати, коли Україна зможе стати повноправним членом НАТО.
Український міністр закордонних справ сказав про це: "Ми хотіли б отримати чесну відповідь на питання, коли".
Ось що він сказав. І яка Ваша відповідь? Яка остаточна відповідь?
Дозвольте мені дати Вам відповідь здалеку, але, тим не менш, дуже пряму. Спасибі, що ви так добре вимовляєте моє ім'я.
Мені вкрай приємно, тому що я родом з Румунії. Я перший заступник секретаря НАТО від країни-новачка в НАТО.
Я був міністром закордонних справ у моїй країні. Я був послом у Вашингтоні, намагаючись переконати союзників запросити мою країну вступити в НАТО.
Хто-небудь сказав нам, коли це станеться? Хто-небудь дав нам урочисту обіцянку, що до такої-то дати ви станете членами НАТО:
ви - Румунія, ви - Болгарія, ви - країни Балтії, ви - всі інші? Ні.
Але Україна веде війну з Росією на своєму кордоні. Пане Джоане, це трохи інша ситуація…
Ми це проходили. Ми межуємо з Росією прямо або побічно, як і країни Балтії, протягом багатьох, багатьох десятиліть. Це не легко.
Я хочу сказати, що бухарестське рішення про відчинені двері залишається в силі.
Воно було підтверджено на нашому саміті, і від нас залежить досягнення консенсусу всередині Альянсу,
а також від наших партнерів в Україні, щоб продовжити шлях реформ.
Ви не збираєтеся давати їм конкретну відповідь, тому що боїтеся реакції Росії?
На даний момент ми працюємо над політикою відчинених дверей.
Наші міністри закордонних справ зустрінуться в грудні наступного року, щоб надати додаткову підтримку країнам-кандидатам.
Вони повинні зберігати віру у власне рішення приєднатися до Заходу.
Вони повинні продовжувати проводити реформи, не заради вступу в НАТО або Європейський Союз, якщо на те пішло, а заради українського народу.
І саме тому я категорично проти ідеї про те, що Росія може мати право вето або ми можемо погодитися на те, щоб у Європі знову з'явилися сфери впливу.
І коли суверенній державі забороняють вступати в ті чи інші військові союзи або структури, в які вона хоче вступити,
і якщо Україна хоче, як і раніше, рухатися в бік Заходу...
Ну, дехто стверджує, що Москва дуже навіть ефективно застосовує цю заборону.
Пане Джоане, у нас, на жаль, закінчився час. Велике спасибі за участь в програмі DW "Зона конфлікту".
Завжди радий. Спасибі.